Wird die erde gerade für die landung von aliens vorbereitet immer wieder hören wir vom terraforming der methode um einen planeten
Mars in eine zweite erde zu verwandeln mit wasser atmosphäre und an pflanzen tieren und so weiter und so fort es könnte
paradiesisch werden auf einem so ganz neu zu einer zweiten erde verwandeln planeten dagegen müssen wir hier bald unseren heimatplaneten
Verlassen wenn es so weitergeht was passiert also auf der erde alien forming die vorbereitung der landung einer anderen spezies
jetzt sind klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
eigentlich ist es schon ein bisschen verrückt stephen hawking
Der sagt dass wir schon bald die erde verlassen müssen es wird nämlich wenn wir so weiter machen ziemlich
ungemütlich auf unserem heimatplaneten nun auch allen masc meint dass wir den mars und weitere planeten im sonnensystem
besiedeln müssen dabei ist es dann noch viel lebensfeindlicher als bei uns auf der erde
terraforming also die verwandlung dieser himmelskörper in zweit erden soll es unter anderem möglich machen und das ist wirklich paradox
was passiert hier wir zerstören unsere erde um dann andere
lebensfeindlichen planeten zu besiedeln das ist wirklich seltsam oder ist das alles schicksal quasi
vorbestimmen ich habe mir dazu mal ein paar gedanken gemacht und das ist wirklich etwas befremdlich also ein gedankenexperiment
es gibt
ein paar indizien die ziemlich wahrscheinlich machen das ist parallele entwicklung der revolution
Hier auf der erde aber auch im ganzen universum gibt hier auf der erde und das finde ich ziemlich verrückt haben sich alle zivilisationen
ähnlich entwickelt alle haben irgendwann städte gebaut den pflanzenbau kultiviert tiere gehalten
Religionen gegründet alle überall egal wo es ist als gäbe es ein entwicklungsmuster als wäre das alles
vorprogrammiert das ist es wahrscheinlich nicht sondern eine folge unserer
begrenzten intelligenz wir wissen nicht was um uns herum passiert und müssen uns in religionen flüchten um das überhaupt annähernd begreifen zu können
was wir aber immer noch nicht tun und wir begreifen offenbar selbst die einfachsten
zusammenhänge nicht und einer davon ist entscheidend das verbrennen fossiler brennstoffe führt zwingend zur unbewohnbar machen der erde denn was passiert
pflanzen haben co2 gebunden der sauerstoffgehalt
stieg durch diese bindung diese pflanzen wurden durch geologische bewegungen unter mächtigen schichten begraben dadurch wurde das co2 dauerhaft
Ja begraben und der atmosphäre entzogen die erde wurde für unsere spezies bewohnbar unsere spezies entwickelt sie sich jetzt
kehren wir diesen prozess aber um und machen die erde wieder für uns unbewohnbar wir holen das gebundene co2
Aus der erde und pusten es in die luft ist scheint mir genau so zwingend wie die gründung von religionen dass das machen
schließlich wurde auch das feuer nicht an einem ort entdeckt sondern von verschiedenen völkern
Parallel und dann in folge eben auch die verbrennung von fossilen brennstoffen
das ist ja auch ganz logisch und zwingend in der abfolge und fast
unabänderlich jede spezies hätte das genauso getan
und wenn sich jetzt vielleicht ja bei der entdeckung der alien mikroben zeigt dass ich leben auch auf anderen himmelskörpern
sehr ähnlich entwickelt dann wäre das eine wirklich
Meint blume erkenntnis es gäbe quasi ein gesetz wie sich leben im universum
entwickelt und ist es quasi vor bestimmt wie das in stufen abläuft aber
in welcher stufe sind wir und warum machen wir das sind wir vielleicht eine zwischenstufe und es gibt noch einen viel größeren plan
Es ist quasi vor bestimmt dass wir hier genau das machen automatisch
wie ein ameisenstaat aber was machen wir dann bereiten wir die erde vielleicht ganz automatisch auf die landung von aliens vor
Diese dann besiedeln werden wenn wir das klima so verändert haben dass sie darauf
Existieren können ich finde die idee ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz so absurd wenn ich mir unsere entwicklung
So bis, heute ansehe allerdings kann es auch ganz profan sein wir sterben aus und eine andere spezies ameisen echsen oder
ähnliche übernehmen die führung auf jeden fall
scheint sich da ein zwingendes muster zu zeigen dass wir nur noch nicht so ganz erkennen wohin geht es also
wir können darüber leider nur spekulieren aber vielleicht wird uns ja der erste kontakt mit aliens die augen öffnen
Er soll ja laut nasa schon bald also den nächsten 20 jahren stattfinden bzw
Geht die nasa davon aus dass wir schon bald
aliens entdecken werden ich bin
schon ziemlich gespannt wenn ihr also als erster neues zum thema aliens und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an
Dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video eben vor ab und garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von pixum
mitmachen und mir themen vorschlagen oder andere vorschläge machen der direkte draht zu mir oder abstimmung machen wir da auch einfach hier draufklicken
und natürlich nicht das abo mit der genau vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken aliens der erste kontakt ja ansonsten
bis dann
bleibt dran